hello we apologize for the delay let's
get started we're glad you've joined us
for this live webinar epigenetics in
human health and disease I am Judy
Oracle glad roots and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by laberd's the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by Xiamen research so I know
Research Corporation has been providing
the scientific community with
comprehensive nucleic acid solutions for
DNA and RNA research and epigenetics for
more than two decades since 1994 it has
been serving me academia and biopharma
scientific communities by providing DNA
and RNA purification products the
company's unique achievements include
development of the first available micro
dilution spin column technology for
nucleic acid purification and in 2000 I
mo was among the first companies to
offer products for epigenetics based
research in 2011 the company launched
its genetic and epigenetic services with
state-of-the-art next-gen sequencing and
bioinformatics technologies to date
Simon maintains the most comprehensive
offering of services for genetic
epigenetic and transcriptome analysis to
learn more visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
the webinar is over please click on the
see e button located in the bottom
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits you can pose questions to the
speakers during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green join a button at lower left I now
present today's speakers Peter Jones PhD
research director and chief scientific
officer at the Van Andel Research
Institute and non dirt on MD PhD
director of systems biology of
reproduction laboratory at the Research
Center for Natural Sciences and senior
research fellow at the Hungarian Academy
of Sciences dr. Jones joined the
University of Southern California in
1977 and served as director of the USC
Norris Comprehensive Cancer Center
between 1993 and 2011 his laboratory
discovered the effects of five is a
sighting on cytosine methylation and he
first established the link between DNA
methylation gene expression and
differentiation he pioneered the field
of epigenetics particularly its role in
cancer and helped develop novel
therapies for cancer dr. Jones is a past
president of the American Association
for cancer research and was elected as a
fellow of the Academy of the AACR in
2013 he has published more than 300
scientific papers and received several
honors including the outstanding
investigator grant from the National
Cancer Institute he and his colleague
dr. Stephen Balin shared the Curt ale
and an award for basic cancer research
from the AAC R in 2009 and Medal of
Honor from the American Cancer Society
in 2011 dr. Tong also holds appointments
at the first Department of Pathology and
experimental cancer research and
maternity clinic some advice University
in Budapest and at the department of
obstetrics and gynecology at USC his
work focuses on placental development
and disease pathways of pregnancy
complications using tools of high
dimensional and systems biology his
thorough findings include the molecular
characterization of placental proteins
including the determination of 91
sequences in 15 species and their study
as biomarkers the discovery of placenta
specific collecting family important in
regulating maternal fetal immune
interactions in primates and the systems
biological characterization of disturbed
placental gene networks in preeclampsia
including a new leader
pathway of deep trophoblast invasion in
humans
dr. tongs multidisciplinary research is
rooted in his experience in distinct
fields to view both speakers complete
vitals visit the lab group's website
dr. Jones will now begin his
presentation titled the cancer epigenome
good I need to present a seminar I'm
going to be talking about the cancer in
genome but I will be mainly focusing on
the role of DNA methylation in
controlling the structure and output of
epigenome and also will then end my talk
with the question of how can we use the
genetic therapies to improve the outcome
of patients with cancer first of all I'd
like to start with a slide or a
histology slide to remind you that the
named chromatin as a term which was no
more than a hundred years ago to
describe the fact that the material
within the nucleus of the cell actually
stained differently from the cytoplasm
and it was called chromatin because it
attracts color in the Greek word
chrome-promo and so what people
discovered very rapidly afterwards is
that if they looked at microscope slides
of cancer tissues for example inside a
human skin the cancerous outgrowth on
the left-hand side of the side is
related but the chromatin in cancer
cells was different and in fact this
altered chromatin is actually a major
diagnostic criterion which pathologists
use to characterize cancer so the
diagnosis of cancers often made on the
or what the credit looks like so we only
now are just beginning to understand why
this might be and the relationship
between DNA methylation and chromatin is
what we'll be focusing on today now
chromatin is rather than amorphous
material but as I'm sure you all know is
actually made up of a beautiful subunit
the nuclear Sun which consists of about
146 base pairs of DNA well wrapped
around an optimal of histones
if you open at the bottom left of the
slide you could see this beautiful beads
in the string structure and over the
last 30 or 40 years we finally beginning
to actually figure out at a final
liberal how long the chromatin is
altered and with respect to them equal
so and how this gives functionality to
to chromatin so the questions we can now
begin to answer is how the histones mark
they have these post translational
modification what histone variants are
they and what do they do it was
respected the function of chromatin
where is the DNA methylated how are the
new person's face is hardly
communicating so finally would be need
to be able to answer these questions and
figure out kernel chromatin operates in
normal cells and how it is altered
during the process of transformation so
the next picture is a structure shown in
the diagram diagrammatic food show the
DNA wrapped around it besides that the
main point being made that most on a
regulation of chromatin occurs in new
tostone depleted regions which actually
allow regulatory factors such as
transcription factors and enhancer
binding proteins etc to recognize the
DNA sequence which is actually concealed
while it is wrapped around a neutral
zones one of the things that has come
out from the work of the Cancer Genome
Atlas and other projects is the
realization which I might point out is
completely unexpected
but many of the genes that modify
chromatin or
mutated and women councils and so this
shows you in this slide some of these
kinds of mutations which you can
discover but some of them are missing
actually because many of the mountain of
money being mutations also occur in
proteins which actually shift the
nucleosomes around and allow the
chromatin to either open or closed to
allow different functionalities to occur
so what we've learned over the last five
years is if many cancer causing
mutations appeared in genes which modify
chromatin but I think it's justifies the
fact that lots of primates and can be
seen under the microscope and is
therefore probably a really valid tool
as we begin to understand how things
have gone wrong but much more
importantly to figure out how we might
be able to design drugs for example
which can target credence and restore a
more normal function to the cell now
finding open areas therefore in other
words where most of the regulation
occurs is a major challenge and of great
importance in figuring out the
regulatory pathways which exist now
mostly the way one does this is to use
enzymes such as DNA's run or micro
proper nucleus which actually can cut
DNA is shown by the scissors and open
areas but actually block cutting there
will be a DNA is read to them in
medicine so one can actually therefore
you lose nuclei from cell phones tweet
with DNA's one or like a couple of
nucleus and find out really open regions
aren't so you can figure out how the
changes occurred during transcriptional
activation for example what's the
structure of enhancers are now in my
group we'd actually decided to adopt a
different strategy to find these open
areas because we're actually interested
in is not just where the open areas are
but how do they move
to where the DNA is methylated for
example but to do this we use a methyl
transferase which is encoded by a virus
that infects algae which actually has
the ability to apply methyl groups to
cytosine residues which are downstream
of a bran so in the slide if you look at
these green horseshoes versus the methyl
transferase so it puts a methyl group on
the cytosine downstream above learning
with which is not normally methylated
cells in which most of the methylation
occurs at the scene which is upstream of
a boy and so if we treat nuclei with the
same time you can see not only where
there are urban areas but we can also
look after sodium bisulfite sequencing
where the actual endogenous DNA
methylation occurred so firstly let me
show you a head-to-head comparison of
these two methods they call it no mercy
for nucleus and occupancy and
methylation sequencing and this is
results from a colon cancer cell line
showing the results for dnase 1 where
red shows you the open areas the c1 c2
c3 and 404 are actually disgusted and
which are the bioinformatics ly
positioned next to this relationship to
their nuclear centimetre region central
so you can see these open regions but if
you look at the right-hand side of this
slide you can see that beautiful amber
here additional information you can see
is announcing where the deep green is
the noublesso depleted region but then
there are these amazing
sequences where you can see phasing of
the nuclear cells very clearly with
green shows accessible and white shows
inaccessible and you can clearly see
where the DNA is open and also how the
neutral zones of things so let's discuss
first of all the structure of insolent
inside as I'm sure you're aware
insulators are often bound by the factor
C T CL now we can use our approach them
to see how the nuclear servants are so
located in this region so using sodium
bisulfite sequencing of individual
molecules following treatment with the
enzyme you can see here that in the a
particular ctcf binding site there is no
endogenous DNA methylation as indicated
by the open right circles the some
sporadic methylation shown black dots
and then if you look down below the
result will be known see where you can
clearly see a region protected exactly
where the sequence here
factor binds and green teal area stood
on either side which indicate where the
DNA can be methylated by this GC enzyme
and without going into any great detail
if we look at this cartoon we can see
that we that where the ctcf sites are
occupied are shown by the anchor the DNA
is inaccessible and that most of the
methylation which occurs the endogenous
methylation although this wasn't shown
in the slide that I showed you is
actually between the new persons and so
that ctcf site is the only a part in
that we see this methylation outside of
the nucleus oh no the poor particles
let's then discuss the structure of our
transcription start sites and I'm going
to focus my attention here on CPG Island
and transcription starts right which are
present at about 60 percent of human
genes
I remember that these regions are very
cg which while the rest of the the
genome is actually CPG into Peter
try and figure out exactly what dealing
that the nation does with transcription
start sites we've used the cell line /
Bert vogelstein and Steve Balin and
Annie Feinberg in which 95% of the
population will imaginated not found and
then by comparing the no see appearance
of these two cell types we can see what
a particular region looks like when it's
methylated and when it's lost its
methylation so the next slide shows you
the kind of thing that we can see so
this shows you on the left-hand side the
HC T 1 and 6 hours and blue on the
left-hand side means unmethylated and in
the DK own that is the cell line which
is missing DNA methylation if you look
at the bottom of slide is 3216 sites
which are now yellow in the in the AC t
106 hours in which DNA methylation is
strongly in this region of the
transcription start site and this
methylation has been lost in the echo
cells because the enzymes have been
crippled by removal and using genetic
normal now if you look at the right hand
side of the slide you can see what
happens with respect to the
accessibility of these regions following
loss of methylation so first of all you
can see on being on the AC T at one at
600 ek ourselves if you look at the
green areas you see not only the
beautiful large areas which are
accessible again you show it by this
green teal appearance but you can also
see the phasing of the new persons on
either side of this region this has
never been seen in the million cells
although it has been seen on whom yeast
now in with the in the red box you see
what happens to those regions which were
methylated in the cancer cells and you
can see what happens when the
methylation is removed by the genetic
knockout that we have discussed now just
a while earlier on
now if you look at this in a bit more
detail about blowing up the region
looking just at the regions which were
yellow ie completely methylated immobile
toxins and they look at what's happening
in the TKR cells in which the nipple
ation is lost we can see that in many
regions we actually gain accessibility
following the loss of DNA methylation
and by coupling an approach together
with chip sneaked in which we look at
the histone modifications we can
actually see that there are two regions
at the target regions which do not
display and you discern depleted region
at the transcriptionstar outside and
those are the bottom image - and
interestingly the ones at the top which
have lost DNA methylation that gained
another silencing mark the polycomb
repressive rod which is shown in red for
histone 3 h3k27 trimethylation in which
the DNA methylation mark has been
switched for a for it for histone
modification which keeps the genes
silent and actually repressed so if we
look in this next slide which i've
skipped one you can see that in fact we
can now figure out what happens and what
the role of DNA methylation is and at
these CPG Islands which have become
abnormally methylated in in the cancer
cells so if you look at the top left I
don't have time to discuss on the right
you can see a CPG Island which is
repressed and inaccessible that has
actually shown clearly on the slide when
we remove the methylation by genetic
knockout two things can happen
on the left hand side we get regions
which become open accessible and the
genes tend to become expressed and can
act it but the majority of promoters in
which we lose the DNA methylation
actually remain repressed by the
activity now of the lysine 27 time
evolution in which there's been what we
call an epigenetic switch former DNA
methylation suppression to a suppression
by the histone mark polygon repressive
mark which it keeps these genes silent
and inaccessible and the thing that I
haven't had a chance to show you very
clearly this is that what something
which we saw which was totally
unexpected was the fact that there is
nuclear sound phasing which is appeared
even in these repressed regions so
something that hadn't been seen before
was this ability of them or Newt
deserves to be actually phased around
regions which are actually not meet them
even accessible and it should not be
actively transcribed I want to briefly
move on to a discussion of enhancers I
have any another five or six minutes to
talk to you and I just want to briefly
show you some exciting information we
have which is actually impressive the
moment in which we have discovered
something completely unexpected with
respect to these enhancers particularly
super enhancers which are large regions
in which large numbers of in concert
units are actually coupled together so
this shows you again and the side using
them see if you look at C 3 which is
cluster 3 a whole set of regions which
it
I mean inaccessible in the rock types
tones which become accessible in the
double knockout cells you can so there's
a lot more green named these regions are
all in enhancers and the DNA methylation
is actually really important in this
region is realm you can see that we go
from yellow to blue which is associated
with us
population now I'm going to have to rush
through the state head so I'm not going
to show you the data itself but just to
go to the summary in order to save some
time to show you that we have discovered
in these enhancer regions regions are
what we call by valency which we are
quite unexpectedly have observed that
the coexistence of a DNA methylation
mark which is considered the course of
repressive mark and a histone
27 right like h3k27 acetylation as
depicted in green which is an active
mark we saw that seeing that it enhances
we have not open disappearances we
actually have a new form of my valency
that's never been seen before which is
actually representative of super
announces it only occurs in these
regions and where the transcription
factors bind the losers are shown by the
Octagon meaning there is no DNA
methylation that we have large regions
of chromatin in which we have both an
active histone mark and a repressive DNA
methylation are coexisting in each other
and so this is very exciting in this
room shortly and be published so to
summarize what I see there I think we
have now looking going back to those
electron micro brats we're getting a
much better idea of how a DNA
methylation histone modifications and
new persona positioning act together so
as you've seen throughout my toolkit DNA
methylation patterns are profoundly
altered in cancer and therefore using
drugs which can inhibit DNA methylation
this seems to be like a ballot treatment
modality now we know the patient is
responding to to firebase assignment in
treatment for example but we don't
actually know why they respond and so I
rather discuss some new data which we
recent
published which suggests that they might
respond for reasons which we would not
have predicted so in this slide which
has occurred to me you can see the sorts
of things we've been thinking are up in
Tamara so we at the top of the slide you
see rexella the CPG Island and during
the post of aging and fetching for
example you can get a Burundian
appellation in the promoter as shown by
the red dots and then during the
formation of cancer of course we can get
the silenced in the tumor suppressor
genes such as P 16 and momentum lining
which results in the cells behaving in
an abnormal fashion and the idea we've
had all along was that met now maybe
what happens with the hyper methylated
drugs this is that we would remove the
speculation and the stall and normal
activity to the cells all right when we
do these initial experiments with
focused on tumor suppressor genes
between a daniel de cabelo is in my lab
we decided to do a test and look to see
what actually happened that are being
targeted and so what we did was to look
at the expression of genes as a function
of time after a 24 hour treatment of
human colon cancer cells to the
dragonfly by a society and at the top of
the side you can see what happens that
after 5 days of treatment there's a
group of genes which is rapidly induced
including tumor antigens and various
other genes and that these genes
subsequently get switched off again as
the cells grow out to treatment but
interestingly at the bottom part slide
you'll see that there are in fact
another group of genes who which takes a
bit longer to get turned on and question
is what are these genes well very
interesting the genes that come on later
are actually probably entered by our
defense pathway so this was very very
interesting and of course if we look at
the top of the slide we didn't see any
viruses expressed and the reason for
that is very simple because there are
actually camp viruses on the arrays that
music
so the idea then came about that maybe
what was actually happening with mr. X
is that they were a retroviruses which
caste which are very prevalent in genome
which are suppressed by DNA methylation
and that mainly what was happening here
was the DNA methylation inhibitors were
turning on the expression of these genes
which resulted on the right hand side
right hand side of the slide in the
induction of the interferon part way as
a result of the formation of
double-stranded RNA within the cytoplasm
so this is a completely different way of
thinking about it and so very recently
about six months ago Daniel de Guevara
and Steve Baylor depend upon similar
findings actually showed in the two
back-to-back papers and cell but this
actually may be the way that new drugs
work but maybe one of the ways in which
they do it so if you look at the right
hand slide a we have the side here and
Bible mimicry that what the drugs are
actually doing is inducing expression of
these retroviruses and that this
previously interferon pathway and cell
death pathways after the stimulation of
genes which recognize double-stranded
RNA whipping the cytoplasm so I just
want to remind you that we focus all of
our statement masters were vast majority
of us Studies on the 1.5% of DNA which
is involved in coding for proteins but
there's all this other material in the
genome including the LTR
retrotransposons
which are actually also silenced not
even in information and that may be the
reason why patients respond to these
kinds of drugs is not just because we
turn on tune suppressor genes it also
because we turn on the retro viruses and
other repetitive DNA s and this is going
to be a very exciting area to look at
now in the future here ladies and
gentlemen I wish you a good day after
this fascinating performance focus on
ones I like to highlight the key
characteristics
central original how to resembles
through canceling genome and how it can
be altered in pathological conditions
leading to pregnancy complications in
addition as an example also social some
related data from our developer aid from
a recent study first of all I would like
to give you a brief summary from the
main presenter functions so in many
cultures the placenta message from night
is a mystical order in Egypt it was
looked at as a second servant or secret
rapper and it was Testament mentioned
about you as a sip of the external soul
in other regions of the world it was
recognized as a helper company another
child to support healthy strong and wise
right as you will look at the slide on
the right the food company on the +
intoxicants three main functions which
complement functions of the highlighted
feature honors while preventing the
fetus from rejection it also protects
against infections and other
environmental factors it exchanges gases
nutrients based products and produces
metabolites one more Sandro fat loss so
it regulates fetal development and
Martenot adaptation to pregnancy
our failure of these functions leads to
the termination of pregnancy for severe
acts of diversity on roles in turn these
adverse outcomes released was to film
about the operation also promised fetal
programming and consequent regard onset
diseases such as diabetes of coronary
heart disease we can look at the
placentas diary of interview life and is
histopathological and more elaborate
recognition can help us understanding
fatal injuries and motivations so how
the epigenetic regulation supports
personal functions and how is this
regulation a little pregnancy
complications the complex functions from
lessons are supported by school back
structure and regulation why the
metabolic and doctrinal functions are
mainly performed by reveals the center
and formulas invasion is a feature of
the exodus trophoblast in many
functional strength the person that
remembers to solid tumors power my
placenta functions are tightly regulated
specially and temporarily this is not
the case the unique features of the
placental official on each support
dysfunctions first I have to mention the
epigenetic reprogramming which of yours
during the pre implementation area as
you see on the left side of the figure
after fertilization immediately the
paternal channel under Bruce active the
motivation why the maternal genome
manipulated by a passive majalis both
channels are gonna tell a bitter at the
time of the implantation and it's in a
higher extent in the embryo and amarka
bley-vroman understand in the placenta
all is an imprinted genes
ribbit secret assists escapees
reprogramming keeping the methylation
status like a single germ cells the
global methylation of the placenta is a
unique feature which is resulting on the
previous process I've shown and this is
very similar to as can be found in
tumors when compared to somatic tissues
recent studies showed large hibernating
domains covering a large portion of the
placenta channel similarly to us in
tumors these domains are consistently
located between regions of low CTG and
gene density G is located between these
domains have opened issue specific
expression
interestingly interrupt and intergenic
regions in these domains have lower
methylation while promoters have higher
methylation in this last you can see
that the low blow by methylation of
placenta louis gen of integrated
retroviruses and retrotransposons to be
expressed in the embryonic early
embryonic period a recent study found
marking risk in the expression of
various repeat elements in parallel
internet elation in the develop in the
amnio as shown for the sign our names in
Figure since this if it's often harbors
crappy promoters and enhancers there the
methylation pearl is the placenta
specific expression where is genes
improbable important wasn't malfunctions
as bottom of the figure another unique
feature is the intermediate percent and
methylation of tumor suppressor gene
promoters which are welcomed completely
methylated in cancer genomes this
difference may reflect the tight
regulation of impassive properties of
the placenta
compared to the tumors in addition
promoters of hundred genes associated
with invasion and was also regulated by
methylation in the placenta class of
genes that is dependent on sweet
energetic regulation in the placenta is
subject to genomic imprinting the parent
operate independent monolith gene
expression the central imprinted genes
regulate maternal resource allocation
and influence fetal growth as well as
prenatal multiples of the developing
Hoarders imprinting is sensitive to
toxic environment passed in line and
this disturbance leads to very small
developmental and physical disorders
imprinted genes tend to be plastered
into chromosomal domains which are
regulated by common
pimping control regions as can you see
on the figure as well this is also the
case from the chromosome 19 microbial
cluster the largest microwave a cluster
in humans it has emergent primates emit
members predominantly or limit expressed
in the twasn't time and many of them are
expressed in some tumors also 19 plus
the microns are the most abundant micron
a species interoperable sense of elastic
axis all probably controlling matter
what an alpha tal signaling to model it
not on another patient pregnancy that
functions in tumors are also under
intensive investigations as you can see
on the right side of the field so the
placental epigenome is very important in
regulating function of the placenta and
the development of the embryo and there
are several factors that are known to
influence on television all like
physiology under different environmental
effects and factors and assisted
reproductive technologies as shown
disruption or multiplication or the
placental epigenome by these factors can
lead to other gene expression constant
and developmental functions if not honor
and fickle adaptation to preserve the
dysfunctions our mother Eve
fetal development and growth
trajectories can be disruptive and
obsolete rare syndromes can develop when
disposing the fetus
also - that was a business but our
number of patients may lead to severe
acute and laborious
death and half publications so therefore
studies of the placental epigenome a
major importance of our understanding of
diseases in pregnancy however several
challenges need to be taken into account
especially the heterogeneity
you know regarding the central regions
cell types gender and just a tional age
also last Studies on that progress
towards uh necessitated and aid was
strengthening culture in terms and
functional relevance of the findings as
you can see the NIH roadmap epigenomics
project has already started to tackle
these issues regarding was the plastron
but you can see on the figure that still
there is a lot more to go now I will
give some insights into the passenger
epigenetic changes in a very severe
complication of pregnancy quadratum Jie
and I also supplement with some data
from our recent collaborative study
records is an obstetrical syndrome which
affects five to eight percent of
pregnancies and causes about 76,000
mater now and hafnium parented us in the
leaders worldwide it is characterized by
hypertension Rotarian you can lead to
organ failure as well
this what organ failure most severely
affected brain kidney liver and
circulation
cardiovascular system of the mother the
fetus is mainly affected by the
detrimental effects of prematurity low
birth weight and figure growth
retardation and often may have severe
brain and lung injuries the long-term
consequences of his injuries and model
patients include metabolic and
cardiovascular diseases later in life
for both the mother and her fetus
it is now bad appreciated that the
placenta has a central role in the
development of preeclampsia
also supported by the fact that the only
specific therapy of preeclampsia so far
is the delivery of the fetus
the placenta reconcile has very many
ideologies which triggered the
initiation of a complex and multistage
43 in Sorachi in the first stage injury
of the exogenous trophoblast lead to the
failure of the transformation of
maternal neutering arteries and the
uneven blood supply to the placenta with
consequence Mustafa's distress he
stressed them in Egypt the placenta Luis
Reyes toxic substances like foreign from
cytokines since it supports micro
particles as well as anti engine
importance as you can see a figure then
this will lead to the empty angio genic
and parameter states in the model which
will result in what you call an injury
and clinical symptoms varies evidences
showed that pregnancy has two major
subtypes Li Po Services has mainly
modest consequences on the fetus and
also the mother while early onset
disease may have very severe impact on
Lasan thought this is what pronouncing
the early onset form as you can see the
figure my labels are fragments here
predominantly caused by madonna under
liabilities in parallel will be more
pronounced and released a photo logic
and gene expression disturbances in
early onset Francia plus an epigenetic
changes are also more in terms in this
software as provided evidenced by
various metals were selected for the
flavor these changes include a higher
global methylation the higher expression
of the element in one in the center
conversely hyper methylation of
commuters and harnesses and low seviche
density regions in the past
it is important that the epigenetic
changes are observed for genes in fluent
in Kiel essential functions namely the
invasion and development so now I would
like to share some data with you from
our multidisciplinary collaboration from
placenta process of pregnancy are we
started in a way that we use placental
transcriptomics and arrive at targeted
epigenetic analysis for business
associate in the genes we use the
microarray data and run a radium gene
quite special network analysis only and
found that differential expressed the
central genes running for major gene
modules which had unrelated expression
the separate expression of these modules
were also evaluated in large number of
cases with qPCR and the most important
findings was that - - out of his for
maybe the software and web and we know
it was very competitive separately
regulated in the placenta and genes in
one of them the red module were very
strongly correlated with blood pressure
does matter no problems and while the
gene expression in the green module was
separately associated first rate and
also problems when looking at potential
hub factors in these modules regulating
their separate expression we noticed
that one of the transcription factors in
the green whatever be the most
correlated expression with other genes
was completely unknown regarding these
expression regulation of functions
network the Selective is for
comprehensive analysis
this transcription factor was fun to
read Emil expressing the placental 1948
issues and both in be loosed an answer
risk of August in first and third
trimester present fast as you can see on
the bottom of the figure in pregnancy
his expression was strongly reduced in
impossi axel use of hablas compared to
the control issues so we knocked down
this gene in the necks of use of a cell
line and a look at microwave and also
the distillation of energies involving
north adhesion and migration important
for social stimulation the comfort his
findings with to PCR and wasn't Eliza
and confirmed to measure placental
inflation individual molecules at the
Iranian 20 levels next was a confirming
that there was strong introduced in
Basel and microwave capacity of
themselves not suggesting that means
gene this transcription factor has key
regulatory hours into first invasion
when look at the promoter of this gene
or repeat as he found many transcription
factor binding science or HIPAA not
ruining me it's a sexual factors are
critically important to part
epithelial-mesenchymal transition and
invasion of interest due to the rapid
promote evolution indigenous species
differed from the last invasion have
more binding sites for these
transcription factors the others with
less invasive plus ultra as you can see
in the top we see far as essays be
proven that the human promoter of this
gene which harbors the most binding
signs were more active upon Z the
overexpression and hypoxia
the promoters of species brandon maka
with less pronounced approximation next
and we looked at names you see as the
additional data
and we found that the promoter from
genes hypermethylated
at embryonic cells compared to somatic
cells on the to repeat elements which
contains the numerous hit one autopilot
science
this was quite pretty interesting and
especially because here my methylation
hinder sniffing our companion and
especially because they also affected
the DNA methylation independent
regulation on geez gene indeed
metropolis like stars because that one
other treatment the expression of the
gene was significantly increase so based
on this data we hypothesized that hyper
methylation of Hippo not rocket science
the suspected differentially methylated
religion may be key in disrupting disco
first invasion possibly in pregnancy our
task the face was not video since
Lois's were available for the study for
the methylation to be any more vigilance
however science is a sign research
preferably passivated for us look at
this region at the nucleotide level
first by some fixed sequence genomic DNA
from primer cycle and since it's a
performers and particle samples from the
same flee [ __ ] and observe the
differential hyper methylation of
opportunity elements in Metropolis then
the laser captured so flawless from the
hundred plus interest that we use for
the previous PCR validation study an
isolated genomic DNA of important the
DNA from patients with early onset
pregnancy had significant
hypermethylation or for city cheese
located at the tool - are combining
science when one of the study repeat
elements compared to controls
importantly one of these CPGs the
observe the negative correlation between
methylation energy expression positive
correlation between met
and percentile histopathological score a
negative correlation between methylation
and persuade this is as collectively
suggest that we observe disruption of
hypermethylation and deepen our combined
exercising the promoter for key
invention regulatory gene directly
affects its expression as well as
placental and fetal development final
part of my story in an important
question I would like to talk about
whether the placental epigenetic marks
all cells in our study and other studies
I mentioned and future works in various
pregnancy complications can be used for
clinical diagnostic purposes in the
future in 1997 Lo and colleagues had
their seminal observation on the
presence of sadly fetal DNA in the
maternal circulation which can account
for about 10% of total selfie DNA in the
maternal plasma and in 2011 we arrived
to the clinical implementation of
non-invasive genetic testing for CSV
fitted in your hair as you consider the
figure it is more important year since
the discovery of fetal methylation
markers in maternal blood and the world
fetal met alone model that was not a
sequence recently as well the question
where future directions lead us it is
rapidly emerging field current
approaches target to look at the ratio
of universal fetal DNA methylation marks
and chromosome specific filter the
initial methylation marks for anomalous
training it is ambition that Rafa bastok
DNA methylation marks that will be
discovered for syndromes in combination
with universal fit alienation marks in
enable the screening of the syndromes in
the early pregnancy
and my final slide is a summary of the
tour so in summary the placental
epigenome resembles to cancer originals
the seldom malignant person televisions
temporary and especially tightly
controlled it is sensitive to exposures
to environmental factors which may
induce variations in placenta accreta
developmental trajectories this may
result in fetal loss onset occurs in
rooms and other onset diseases the use
of trauma specific epigenetic markers
may become useful tools for early
non-invasive induction of pregnancy
complications I would like to thank you
for your attention and was the
contribution of my colleagues and
collaborators involved in this study and
the funding the agencies for providing
support for our studies as well thank
you for your attention and ready to
answer your questions
thank you dr. Cohn and now we will
briefly turn it over to our sponsors I
know research dr. Keith Breuer manager
of epigenetics at Simon research would
like to share a few items
all right thank you Judy thank you to
Peter and gobbler and especially thank
you to the all the attendees listening
in today so my name is Keith and I am
the epigenetics service project manager
here at Zemo research for those of you
listening and watching who may not be
that familiar with Xiamen research I
would like to take this opportunity to
share a quick message about who we are
and what we do so for nearly 25 years
samo has been proudly serving the
scientific community by providing
innovative reliable and high-quality
research tools that are both simple to
use and reliable in their performance
that most first commercial product is
the easy East transformation kit
launched in 1994 and facilitated
utilization of the yeast two-hybrid
technique popular at the time
two years later we launched the first
wave of our DNA purification products
featuring our unique micro evolution
spin column technology in 2001 as Emma
demonstrated an early commitment to the
growing field of epigenetics research by
launching the first of our patented
lined by sulfide chemistry conversion
kits to streamline the process of DNA
methylation detection our bisulfite
chemistry's are now the most frequently
cited and highest rated in the
scientific literature as our line of
epigenetics products grew in popularity
zamel research became known as the
epigenetics company in 2008 that same
year Xiamen opened up its European
headquarters in Freiburg Germany more
recently Zemo has launched a
comprehensive suite of epigenetics
services that makes a genome-wide
epigenetic analysis available to all
researchers our next-gen at the genetic
sequencing services features state of
the art sample prep technologies
workflows and cutting-edge
bioinformatics for the analysis of whole
genome bisulfite sequencing genome-wide
bisulfite sequencing as well as targeted
DNA methylation analysis we also offer
services for genome-wide DNA hydroxy
methylation detection and chip seek for
the study of DNA and their protein
binding partners also gene expression in
the form of RNA seek to investigate
small and regulatory RNAs as well as
coding RNAs mass spectrometry for the
very precise quantification of
epigenetic modifications and of course
data analysis to date is almost services
services have analyzed data from
billions of sequence reads generated
across hundreds of projects involving
thousands of samples from academic
government nonprofit and commercial
entities alike and data generated
through Simoes services have been cited
in numerous academic journals and at
work such as percent what was presented
during this webinar today in total
Zalman research offers a unique set of
products and service solutions from
microbial and microbial mix research the
sample collection and DNA and RNA
purification and of course kits and
services to facilitate at genetic
studies to learn more I invite
interested parties to visit our website
at wwlp.com worked email us at either
services at Zama research comm or info
at Zama research comm thanks again for
your attention thank you all for your
informative presentation so a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box down by clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Jones and dr.
Tong will answer as many questions as
time permits and the first one is a
two-parter at what point is using the
altered color of chromatin useful in
detecting the presence of cancer and so
at what point of the cancers growth can
we detect the color change
you
I'm sorry I didn't realize this first
okay um great that dr. Jones is back
with us and dr. Jones let me just repeat
the question for you it's a two-parter
so at what point is using the altered
color of chromatin useful in detecting
the presence of cancer and so at what
point of the cancerous growth can we
detect the color change like the follow
gist and ironic and I'm not a
pathologist so let me say that again the
color change he is associated with
chromatin changes that can be observed
by pathologists I don't think anybody
knows exactly yet when in the cancer
person is the chromatin becomes deranged
to the point that someone can actually
see it under the light microscope but
what I can tell you is that changes in
DNA methylation are very common in human
cancer and can often be detected in
tissues with for the emergence of a
cancer so it's likely that these changes
occur at a molecular level much earlier
than they can be seen through the
microscope by a pathologist
okay next our energy dependent micro RNA
flanking sequences mostly likely linked
from DNA methylation to RNA mediated
substitutions and epigenetically
affected cell type differentiation I'm
really sorry but I was not able to hear
the question regarding I think micro RNA
and cancer so you won't have to repeat
it - I don't know if you could just
repeat the question would be helpful
absolutely
the question is for energy dependent
micro RNA flanking sequences the most
likely link from DNA methylation to RNA
mediated substitutions and
epigenetically affected cell type
differentiation so they so the answer is
rather complicated I don't know exactly
what you mean by energy dependent micro
RNA
flanking sequences micro RNA is small
RNA sequences which can be controlled by
DNA methylation and changes in micro RNA
expression of forces are associated with
cancer phenotypes and can be actually
reversed by DNA methylation inhibitors
however the relationship between micro
RNAs and energy I think a little bit
unclear and I not certain that I can
answer the question at any more detail
than that
okay dr. Jones this next question was
posed specifically for you in genetic
disorders do you expect defects in
epigenetic signatures in the epigenome
yeah so this is a very very interesting
question
so you know we know of these mutations
which I talked about which occur in
epigenetic modifiers and we know they're
associated with cancer we know that they
can occur you know very early in the
carcinogenic process some of them occur
later but actually it was still very
ignorant of how the mutations actually
are translated so to speak in changing
the epigenome so the jury's still out on
exactly how this works I think the main
thing is that there are many more
mutations in epigenetic modifiers than
we anticipated
that clearly these can occur in a very
early stage in constantly Genesis but
exactly comments changes on to the
epigenome is not yet known but I can
tell you there are certainly a lot of
people working on that and so I would
expect us to be able to tell that the
next few years or so much more about how
these changes actually are meaningful in
making enormous cell into a cancer cell
this next one is also for dr. Jones can
you discuss whether DNA methylation and
histone modification is always related
yes sir so we're beginning to get a
fairly good idea now of the relationship
between a DNA methylation and histone
modification so clearly active genes for
example tend to be marked by low DNA
methylation at the promoter
transcription start site and high levels
of histone modifications which are
associated with active gene expression
such as assimilation of the lysine
residues on lead on histone monkeys
so in general is a very good sort of
correlation between DNA methylation and
active histone marks and those genes
which are active and the other way
around and the genes when they are be
silenced so what was interesting about
what I talked to you about was the
survive alien sea which was seen in the
super analysis which is very much
unexpected in which we see botha and
negative log so to speak that is histone
excuse me DNA methylation coexisting
with an actor histone and so this was
unexpected and it might have something
to do with the function of super enhance
and Student Development in cancer but
yes we know quite a great deal about it
we know how to so many to by the large
extent how these two systems
communication channel
okay next one is for doctor ton on what
basis was the control for the
preeclampsia studies chosen the Contras
were thank you for the question the
contours were completely just issued age
matched cases so for term pregnancy
cases we use term controllers for
treatment programs or early onset
program services we use return controls
it's well known that we presented
epigenomics changing and DNA methylation
in the present our journalist is
changing his gestational age so this is
a very important factor especially in
his study we needed to take into account
so this was not only completely just
issue in age matched case control study
thank you the next person thanks you for
your talk and asks does the increase in
birth weight relate to increased
incidence of preeclampsia
let's let's we will post the next one to
to dr. Jones hey this person would like
to know if we could design the hypo
methylating drugs depending on the
structure and sequence of the
neighboring sequences of the methylated
ones in cancer cells so that the hypo
methylation does not occur at random
sites in the genome maybe you let me
know if you need me to repeat that one I
heard the question thank you but look
this this is a very interesting question
and so the fact is is that the DNA
methylation rights that we have at the
moment actually are fairly limited they
inhibit DNA methylation across the
Acosta gene they inhibit evaporation
everywhere and so they really you might
think well okay that means they're
nonspecific but they actually are
nonspecific in terms of D methylated DNA
but what is actually very interesting is
when you remove the drug and the cell
begins to remap like a diamond there is
actually quite a lot specificity at that
stage so they're not so the net effect
is is that different regions of the
genome respond to demethylation
differently and I can't think of a way
at the moment that we could design a
drug which we could use in the clinic
for example which would inhibit
methylation in specific areas but you
know we began to think that maybe this
is a great advantage for them strengths
because they are really genomic
medicines in other words they because
they do so much it might be advantageous
for cells might actually open up new
pathways for different in different
cells that in fact would be beneficial
to the patient so this is sort of very
in the opposite direction to what you
might call precision medicine we try not
just one particular pathway at a time
that may be turn
tumor-suppressor genes turning on micro
arteries turning on endogenous
retroviruses etc may have advantages in
terms for example making the cell more
sensitive to drug therapies are more
sensitive to ignore therapy an exception
but it's a very very good question at
the moment that he knows how to do this
here's another one for you dr. Jones how
much energy does RNA have as compared to
DNA before transcription occurs so I'm
not sure if I understand this question
because we don't normally think of
Iranian DNA as having energy per se and
they we mostly think of them as being as
you know storage of information there's
an eddy code or the code that that can
be used to direct the formation of
proteins for example but I don't think
that thinking about them as being stores
of energy this really really appropriate
so I think more of the time you think of
them misleading information storage
rather than energy sources
okay now dr. ton um does the increase in
birth weight relate to increased
incidence of preeclampsia
the case control study and we didn't
look at the incidence of preeclampsia
anyways we used fetuses in our study
which who were appropriate for the
gestational age was more for gestational
age but we didn't have frequencies from
at large for gestational age so our
study was completely inappropriate to
answer this question
you
this one is for doctor
how do you select a candidate gene
effectively for DNA methylation research
in certain cancers so how do you would
select a gene for DNA methylation search
is really based upon the particular
interest for example if you're
interested in tumor suppressor genes you
would tend to focus on genes such as P
16 P 15 mlh1 18mpg
which we know very frequently becoming
abnormally methylated in a promoter
during the formation of it canceling as
I pointed out to you earlier and it
seems like we'd be you know focus on
genes which were rotten about the list
at the epigenome Emogene on so there are
for example these retro viruses which
are in fact suppressed by DNA
methylation in normal cells in which we
can turn on using these clearance
finally I must say that you know all of
our focus of tomorrow has been on on the
promoters of genes and we've sort of
neglected and ignored the rest of the
antenna and as if you've heard from Greg
both my program we've sort of ignored
also the function that enhances and and
ctcf binding sites for no as their
potential role in cancer so the pendulum
is now switched we're now longer now
just focused on tumor suppressor gene
abnormal DNA methylation we try to look
at the list of the epigenome as well and
that's why I think it's going to be a
very exciting time because we sort of
were solely focused on one thing that we
sort of forgot about everything else and
some of these things like enhance of
methylation may be very very important I
mean the formation of the clansmen
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Jones and dr. Khan for their
presentations do you have any final
comments share this to a gentleman yes I
first of all I wanted to thank you for
allowing me to participate in this
webinar I think it's a very very
interesting exciting time in the field
of epigenetics particularly as it
relates to the relationship between DNA
methylation and the functioning of
relativity and I think that this is not
just you know the basic science which is
very exciting interesting we now have a
full series of new drugs most of which I
didn't have time to talk about which
target these changes and so I'm hoping
that we'll see Miami much more knowledge
was so much better responses to none of
cancer patients are to these kinds of
millions so thank you very much
this is my privilege to believe it too
and and present television on the study
some percentage Jonas is an imaginary
field a very interesting field and a lot
to do as you will see in my figures and
the importance of it least is that such
a single cell very treatment and the
roots of the other specifically
syndromes align placental epigenomic
changes very early in pregnancy so if
you can find those changes which are
rooted in embryogenesis or even earlier
when there is a hope to develop new
diagnostic tools in early pregnancy and
hopefully also some Terra products as
well knowing that this is very
ventricular the first when you are
talking about to patients did imagine
and ability thank you very much for your
attention
it was a great time here and then I hope
that these thoughts I presented
generated many questions and and
hopefully either scale switch on the
fearless
thank you I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions we would also like
to thank our sponsors imal research for
underwriting today's webcast this is an
educational webinar on us offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over click on the seee button
located in the bottom left corner of
your webpage and follow the process of
obtaining your credits this webcast can
be viewed on-demand through October 11th
2016 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye